les banques sont souvent questionnées
sur la sincérité de leur engagement
climatique alors pourquoi ne
récompenses-t-elle pas les entreprises
qui ont une démarche responsable en
d'autres termes proposer des taux de
crédit plus bas aux entreprises engagées
dans le développement durable
mais quels sont les conditions pour y
accéder quel projet peuvent être
financés est-ce réellement intéressant
pour en savoir plus nous allons à
Saint-Malo en Bretagne
[Musique]
on a une bonne commande en République
tchèque ou 300 hectares un agriculteur
qui a pris 300 hectares d'un coup
Richard est responsable du développement
chez Gaïa Go une PME qui conçoit des
biostimulants des solutions
indispensables pour les agriculteurs ici
on fabrique des produits 100% naturels
pour améliorer les seuls revitaliser les
sols ces produits ils vont aider
l'agriculteur à mieux travailler leur
sol ils vont aider l'agriculteur à avoir
des plantes plus résistantes aux
maladies et aux agresseurs à réduire
leur dépendance aux engrais de synthèse
les retours clients sont bons et gayago
se retrouvent sélectionnés parmi les
meilleurs entreprises de l'agritech sa
solution naturelle prête à être
pulvérisée dans les champs et rapidement
victime de son succès alors pour
satisfaire toujours plus de clients
l'entreprise prend une décision radicale
pour accélérer cette croissance on a
construit cette usine et on est passé de
400 à 4 millions de litres produit par
an et ça ça nous a permis de passer de
cinq pays où on commercialiser les
produits à une douzaine de pays
aujourd'hui dans toute l'Europe
des locaux plus grands des outils de
production plus performants et un
laboratoire dernier cri pour développer
les futurs produits de la marque mais
tout cela a un coût alors pour y
parvenir Charles a dû faire un effort
important à l'échelle de son entreprise
emprunter un million d'euros on en est
où aujourd'hui comment vous comment vous
avez vécu ça puis quel est votre
perception de aujourd'hui on arrive à
15000 hectares qui sont revitalisés
grâce à ce prix impact pour réaliser
cette petite folie Christophe Pinault
lui a octroyé un crédit un peu
particulier un prêt à impact mais de
quoi s'agit-il exactement le vrai impact
en fait c'est quelque chose d'assez
simple et il s'agit de mettre en place
un prêt dont le taux d'intérêt va être
bonifié et cette bonification elle est
assise sur un certain nombre de critères
que l'entreprise va choisir dans le
respect de sa trajectoire RSE ces
critères extra-financiers peuvent
concerner l'environnement et les efforts
mis en oeuvre par l'entreprise pour
réduire son impact sur la planète mais
cela peut également concerner la parité
des effectifs et légalité
professionnelle chaque année
l'entreprise doit rendre des comptes au
banquiers et démontrer qu'elle a tenu
ses engagements vous pouvez très bien
une première année avoir du mal à
atteindre les critères c'est
complètement possible donc la
bonification n'est pas n'est pas
déclenchée et mais chaque année on va
faire un point donc une année vous
pouvez déclencher la bonification
l'année suivante ne pas ne pas le faire
et ça pendant toute la durée du crédit
ce qui est intéressant c'est d'avoir une
trajectoire dans la durée et d'être
capable justement de justifier la
performance sur le moyen long terme pour
convaincre la banque de lui octroyer un
prêt à impact et obtenir une ristourne
de 0,1% sur les intérêts d'emprunt
Charles a mis en avant la capacité de
ses produits à emprisonner le carbone
une fois pulvérisé dans les champs ce
nouveaux modes de financement durable à
levant en poupe à elle seule la Caisse
d'Epargne a mis en place 580 millions
d'euros de prêts à impact dans la région
Pays de la Loire en seulement un an on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'exemples mais je
peux je peux vous en citer deux on a
l'entreprise terre d'Armor qui dans le
domaine de du logement et du logement
social en particulier à enclencher un
très grand programme de travaux de
rénovation énergétique puis un deuxième
exemple c'est le projet grain de sail
qui est un navire à voile un voilier qui
transporte des fèves de cacao que nous
allons financer et qui là aussi a une
vision de réduction de son impact
environnemental extrêmement avancé
les entreprises qui respectent les
conditions peuvent empocher la
bonification mais elles peuvent
également la redistribuer à des
associations ou des clients tu vois deux
poignées de vers de terre je pense que
c'est pas mal c'est le cas de gaïgo qui
a choisi de reverser le gain à ses
clients agriculteurs
en fait tout simplement ça va en phase
un peu avec le discours que Gaïa Gomes
me transmet depuis le début de notre
rencontre en fait c'est à dire que ils
sont au service des agriculteurs et au
fond moi en tant que ferme référence
c'est quelque chose que je ressens
aujourd'hui on a plus le temps de
financer les actions qui qui servent à
rien on doit financer des actions qui
ont un impact positif sur la planète
c'est dans l'air du temps c'est plus que
les résultats c'est nécessaire et c'est
urgent
la Caisse d'Epargne n'est pas la seule à
distribuer des prêts à impacts BNP
Paribas Société Générale la Banque
Postale le Crédit Agricole toutes les
grandes banques en proposent également
au PME une façon pour les établissements
bancaires d'être cohérents avec leurs
engagements en matière de finance
durable
[Musique]